je trouve qu'au contraire un couple
moderne c'est un couple qui justement
qui est fidèle c'est tout l'inverse
c'est effectivement plus je suis
d'accord honnêtement les deux là
vraiment je vais m'énerver sérieusement
non non je te le dis fais gaffe à ta
gueule j'ai changé
tout moi
je parle de quelqu'un de qui non fais
gaffe et il a changé depuis la semaine
prochaine
[Rires]
je te le dire
et foutu
donc toi c'est pour Fatou oui mais toi
non
mais c'est dur hein de la fidélité c'est
dur donc moi je suis avec beaucoup de
tentation non mais je suis en désaccord
parce que tu viens de dire quand même
c'est affolant
en train de dire
mais c'est ce que tous les hommes
mais c'est une honte que tu
et conquérir ou reconquérir toujours sa
femme qui est trompée ou pas c'est ce à
quoi on essaie de s'atteler et c'est
difficile voilà c'est ce que je voulais
dire que les rien de plus moi c'est pas
clair du tout ton histoire
franchement non mais ton histoire n'est
pas clair alors si tu aimes ta femme
tout simplement
bravo Jean-Marie et donc même si la
fille elle est d'accord toi tu étais une
petite voix qui te dit bah non tu peux
pas faire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Gilles est terrible
je demande des excuses ok je fais jamais
ça je demande des excuses de tout le
monde et la gente féminine c'était parce
que tu viens la fidélité c'est dur
excuse-toi auprès
s'il te plaît
c'est dur que je regarde machine
du coeur et la fidélité du slips
dans les deux
voilà toi
réunion la même personne qu'est-ce que
tu dis vous avez la fidélité du cœur et
la même personne ça veut dire que vous
dissociez le cœur et le sexe pas du tout
ce qu'on vient de dire avec mon ami
Géraldine elle est venue à votre
rescousse
qui tombe sur une occasion par exemple
je peux vous dire que dans le bois de
Boulogne par exemple on roule plus vite
les couilles vides
que les soins finir que les couilles
pleines
le gars il avance fort
[Musique]
et qui a écrit vide il trace à la maison
parce qu'il est fidèle
familiale
quand même oui toi oui c'est quoi votre
question là tu vas encore me dire des
conneries c'est vrai c'est vrai que je
pense qu'effectivement je suis d'accord
avec Gilles tu dis scandaleux on voit
qu'on puisse dire un plateau
d'être fidèle ah ouais c'est très facile
non mais je dis je disais je parlais de
Fatou et je dis qu'il y a des tentations
ça tout Oui écoutez je vais vous dire
quelque chose
[Rires]
[Musique]
et toi j'entends tu as rien dit mais tu
penses quand même
vous êtes en train de me tenir dans la
maison
vous êtes en train de me tomber dessus
pour pas raconter vos histoires et tout
c'est trop pratique donc toi
et moi dans le camion tu vas raconter
Lamborghini et toi Bigard allez-y non
mais c'est bon quoi que vous faites à
Gilles est dégueulasse
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça me dégoûte
scandaleux c'est scandaleux
depuis plusieurs jours à plusieurs jours
c'est-à-dire tu lutte contre
l'infidélité
et comme vous me dites souvent c'est pas
parce qu'on est au régime
c'est pas parce qu'on est au régime
qu'on peut pas défoncer le buffet à
volonté
qu'on peut pas regarder le menu mais
c'est lui qui se met à défoncer tout le
monde qu'est-ce que je te dise